est allé voir ce qui avait été amené sur le rivage
lors d'une récente tempête.
Et sur un coin d'herbe juste au bord de l'eau,
il trouva une combinaison de plongée.
Elle était noire, grise et de mauvaise qualité.
De chaque jambe de la combinaison
sortaient deux os blancs.
Il s'agissait, évidemment, de restes humains.
En général, en Norvège, les morts sont rapidement identifiés.
La police a alors commencé à chercher
parmi les avis de recherche locaux
et nationaux,
ainsi que parmi des incidents possiblement en lien.
Ils n'ont rien trouvé.
Ils ont lancé une analyse ADN
et entrepris une enquête internationale avec Interpol.
Toujours rien.
Il s'agissait de quelqu'un qui ne semblait manquer à personne.
Une vie invisible, avec comme destin une tombe sans nom.
Un mois plus tard,
la police norvégienne a été contactée par la police hollandaise.
Deux mois auparavant, eux aussi avaient trouvé un corps
portant la même combinaison
et n'avaient aucune information quant à l'identité de la personne.
La police hollandaise avait réussi à tracer la combinaison
grâce à une puce électronique qui y était intégrée.
Ils ont donc pu établir
que les deux combinaisons avaient été achetées par la même personne,
au même moment,
le 7 octobre 2014,
dans la ville de Calais, située sur la Manche.
Mais c'est tout ce qu'ils ont pu trouver.
Le client avait payé en liquide,
et le magasin n'avait pas de caméra de surveillance.
C'est donc devenu un affaire classée.
Avec un collègue photographe, Tomm Christiansen,
nous en avons entendu parler et ça nous a choqués.
Et on s'est posé la question évidente : qui étaient ces gens ?
A l'époque, je connaissais à peine Calais,
mais il m'a fallu très peu de temps pour tout comprendre.
Calais est connue pour deux choses :
c'est l'endroit en Europe continentale le plus proche de la Grande-Bretagne,
et de nombreux migrants et réfugiés vivent dans ce campement,
et essayent désespérément de rejoindre la Grande-Bretagne.
Et c'est ici qu'on a trouvé une réponse plausible quant à l'identité des corps,
et la police a trouvé la même.
Car si vous, moi ou quelqu'un ayant une connexion ferme à l'Europe
disparaissait au large des côtes françaises, nous le saurions.
Vos proches vous déclareraient disparu.
La police mènerait l'enquête, les médias sauraient,
et il y aurait des photos de vous dans la rue.
Il est difficile de disparaître sans laisser de trace.
Mais si vous fuyez la guerre en Syrie,
et que votre famille, si vous en avez une encore,
ne sait pas forcément où vous êtes,
et que vous êtes ici illégalement,
parmi des milliers d'autres arrivant et repartant chaque jour...
Eh bien, si un jour vous disparaissez, personne ne le saura.
On ne vous cherchera pas car personne ne saura que vous avez disparu.
Et c'est ce qui est arrivé à Shadi Omar Kataf
et Mouaz Al Balkhi, de Syrie.
Tom et moi sommes allés à Calais pour la première fois en avril,
et après trois mois d'enquête, on pouvait enfin raconter l'histoire
de comment ces deux jeunes hommes ont fui la guerre en Syrie,
se sont retrouvés bloqués à Calais,
et ont ensuite acheté des combinaisons de plongée, pour mourir noyés
dans leur tentative de traverser la Manche pour rejoindre l'Angleterre.
Cette histoire raconte que nous avons tous un nom,
une histoire, et que nous sommes tous quelqu'un.
Mais c'est aussi une histoire qui illustre la vie des réfugiés en Europe aujourd'hui.
C'est donc ici que notre enquête a commencé.
A Calais.
En ce moment, entre 3500 et 5000 personnes habitent ici.
Dans des conditions affreuses.
Il a été nommé le pire camp de réfugiés en Europe.
L'accès à l'eau et à la nourriture est restreint,
tout comme l'accès aux soins...
Les maladies et les infections y sont largement répandues.
Et ils restent là-bas car ils veulent atteindre l'Angleterre
pour pouvoir demander l'asile.
Pour ce faire, ils se cachent dans des camions qui prennent le ferry,
ou bien l’Eurotunnel,
ou alors ils se glissent dans les tunnels pendant la nuit,
et essayent de se faufiler dans les trains.
La plupart ont choisi la Grande-Bretagne car ils parlent déjà la langue,
et donc ils pensent que ce sera plus facile de tout recommencer là.
Ils veulent travailler, étudier,
ils veulent pouvoir continuer leurs vies.
La plupart sont très instruits et qualifiés.
Si vous alliez à Calais et leur parliez,
vous verriez des avocats, des politiciens,
des ingénieurs, des designers, des fermiers, des soldats...
Il y a de tout.
Mais qui sont tous ces gens ?
On l'oublie lorsque l'on parle des migrants et des réfugiés.
Car en général on parle de statistiques.
Il y a 60 millions de réfugiés dans le monde.
Cette année, environ 500 000 ont traversé la Méditerranée pour arriver en Europe,
et environ 4000 d'entre eux sont maintenant à Calais.
Mais ce ne sont que des numéros.
Et ils ne nous disent pas qui sont ces personnes,
d'où ils viennent, ou encore pourquoi ils sont venus ici.
Je veux vous parler de l'un d'entre eux.
Voici Mouaz Al Balkhi, 22 ans, de Syrie.
On a entendu parler de lui dès notre première visite à Calais
quand on cherchait des preuves pour nos théories.
Après peu, on nous a raconté l'histoire d'un homme syrien
qui habitait à Bradford, en Angleterre,
et qui cherchait désespérément son neveu, Mouaz, depuis des mois.
La dernière fois qu'on avait eu de ses nouvelles
était le 7 octobre 2014.
Soit le même jour où les combinaisons avaient été achetées.
Nous nous sommes rendus à Bradford pour rencontrer cet homme.
Nous avons pris un échantillon de son ADN,
puis nous avons eu des empreintes de Mouaz
grâce à un membre de la famille vivant en Jordanie.
Quand l'analyse fut terminée, il fut déterminé
que le corps retrouvé sur la plage au Pays-Bas
était le corps de Mouaz Al Balkhi.
Et en menant cette enquête,
nous avons pu découvrir l'histoire de Mouaz.
Il est né à Damas, la capitale de la Syrie, en 1991.
Il a grandi dans une famille de la classe moyenne.
Son père, au centre, est un ingénieur chimiste
qui a passé 11 ans en prison en raison de son opposition au régime.
Pendant que son père était emprisonné,
Mouaz s'est chargé de ses trois sœurs.
C'était son genre.
Mouaz fait des études en ingénierie électrique
à l'université de Damas.
Après quelques années de guerre,
lui et sa famille ont fui Damas pour la Jordanie.
Son père ne trouvait pas de travail en Jordanie
et Mouaz ne pouvait plus continuer ses études.
Il a estimé que la meilleure solution pour aider sa famille
était d'aller quelque part où il pourrait finir ses études,
et ensuite trouver un travail.
Il est alors allé en Turquie.
Mais en Turquie, il n'a pas été admis à l'université.
Et après être parti de Jordanie en tant que réfugié,
il ne pouvait plus revenir.
Et donc, il décida d'aller en Grande-Bretagne,
où son oncle habitait.
Il réussit à se rendre en Algérie, il marcha jusqu'en Libye,
où il paya un passeur pour faire la traversée en bateau jusqu'en Italie,
puis il se rendit à Dunkerque,
juste à côté de Calais, et de la Manche.
On sait qu'il a essayé au moins 12 fois de traverser la Manche,
en se cachant dans un camion, sans succès.
Mais, à un moment donné, il a dû perdre espoir.
Selon nos informations, sa dernière nuit a été passée
dans un hôtel bon marché près de la gare de Dunkerque.
On a trouvé son nom dans le registre de l'hôtel.
Le jour d'après, il est allé à Calais, dans un magasin de sport,
un peu avant 20h,
accompagné de Shadi Kataf.
Ils ont acheté des combinaisons de plongée.
La vendeuse du magasin est probablement
la dernière personne à les avoir vus en vie.
On a essayé de savoir où et comment Shadi a rencontré Mouaz,
mais on n'a pas réussi.
Néanmoins, ils ont une histoire similaire.
On a entendu parler de Shadi car son cousin, qui habite en Allemagne,
avait lu une traduction sur Facebook de l'histoire de Mouaz.
On l'a alors contacté.
Shadi, un peu plus âgé que Mouaz,
avait aussi grandi à Damas.
C'était un travailleur.
Il tenait un atelier de pneus avant de travailler dans une imprimerie.
Il habitait avec sa nombreuse famille,
jusqu'à ce que leur maison soit bombardée au début de la guerre.
La famille s'est alors réfugiée dans le Camp Yarmouk, toujours à Damas.
Yarmouk est décrit comme le pire lieu sur Terre.
On les a bombardés, assiégés,
ils ont été pris d'assaut par l’État Islamique,
et ils ont été privés d'approvisionnement pendant des années.
Après une visite, un représentant de l'ONU a commenté :
« Ils avaient mangé toute l'herbe, il n'en restait plus. »
D'une population initiale de 150 000 personnes,
on suppose qu'il en reste seulement 18 000 aujourd'hui.
Shadi et ses sœurs ont pu s'échapper.
Leurs parents sont encore coincés là-bas.
Shadi et une de ses sœurs ont fui en Libye.
C'était après la chute de Khadafi,
mais avant que la Libye ne bascule dans la guerre civile.
Et dans ces dernières moments de stabilité en Libye,
Shadi s'est mis à la plongée sous-marine.
Apparemment, il passait presque tout son temps sous l'eau.
Il est tombé amoureux de l'océan.
Quand il a décidé qu'il n'était plus possible de rester en Libye,
vers la fin août 2014,
il a voulu aller en Italie, et y travailler en tant que plongeur.
La réalité n'a pas été si simple.
On ne sait pas grand chose sur ses voyages,
car il ne pouvait pas beaucoup communiquer avec sa famille.
Mais on sait que ça a été difficile.
Vers la fin de septembre,
il vivait dans la rue, quelque part en France.
Le 7 octobre, il a appelé son cousin en Belgique,
et il lui a expliqué sa situation. Il lui a dit :
« Je suis à Calais et j'ai besoin que tu viennes prendre mon sac et mon ordi,
car j'ai pas l'argent pour payer les passeurs et aller en Angleterre,
mais je vais m'acheter une combinaison, et y aller à la nage. »
Son cousin a essayé de le convaincre de ne pas le faire,
mais le portable de Shadi n'avait plus de batterie,
et il s'est éteint pour ne plus jamais se rallumer.
Les restes de Shadi ont été retrouvés trois mois plus tard,
à 800 km,
dans une combinaison de plongée, sur une plage, à Norvège.
Il y attend toujours ses funérailles
et aucun membre de sa famille ne pourra être présent.
Certains pourraient penser que l'histoire de Mouaz et Shadi
est une histoire sur la mort.
Mais je ne suis pas d'accord.
Pour moi, ceci est l'histoire de deux questions, qu'on se pose tous :
« Qu'est-ce qu'une vie meilleure ? »
« Que suis-je prêt à faire pour l'avoir ? »
Pour moi et beaucoup d'entre vous,
une vie meilleure pourrait être
de faire plus de ce qu'on considère important,
que ce soit de passer plus de temps avec nos familles et amis,
de partir en voyage,
ou bien de pouvoir acheter le nouveau gadget,
ou d'avoir une nouvelle paire de baskets
Et il est relativement facile pour nous d'avoir tout cela.
Mais si on fuit une zone de guerre,
les réponses à ces deux questions changent drastiquement.
Une vie meilleure est une vie en sécurité.
C'est une vie en dignité.
Une vie meilleure, c'est de ne pas se faire bombarder.
C'est de ne pas avoir peur de se faire enlever.
C'est de pouvoir envoyer ses enfants à l'école,
de pouvoir aller à l'université,
ou de trouver un travail et d'être capable de subvenir aux besoins de sa famille.
Une meilleure vie serait une vie avec quelques possibilités,
et non aucune possibilité.
Ceci est une motivation forte.
Ce n'est pas dur d'imaginer,
qu'après quelques semaines, ou même quelques mois
passés dans des conditions pareilles,
vivant dans les rues ou sous des conditions ignobles dans un camping
qui porte le nom idiot et raciste de « jungle »,
la plupart d'entre nous serions capables de faire tout et n'importe quoi.
Si je pouvais demander à Shadi et à Mouaz,
au moment où ils ont plongé dans les eaux gelées de la Manche,
ils me diraient sûrement: « ça vaut le risque ».
Car ils ne voyaient plus aucune autre solution.
C'est ça, le désespoir.
Et c'est ça aussi la réalité d'être un réfugié en Europe, en 2015.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Bruno Giussani : Merci, Anders.
Voici Tomm Christiansen,
qui a pris la plupart des photos, ensemble ils ont créé ce reportage.
Tomm, vous êtes récemment retournés à Calais,
dans un troisième voyage,
et après la publication de cet article...
L'endroit a-t-il changé ? Qu'avez-vous vu ?
Tomm C : La première fois qu'on est allé à Calais,
il y avait environ 1500 réfugiés.
Ils vivaient dans des conditions difficiles, mais ils gardaient espoir.
La dernière fois, c'était plus grand, peut-être 4 ou 5000 personnes.
Ça avait un air un peu plus permanent, les ONG étaient arrivées sur place,
il y avait une petite école.
Mais les réfugiés sont là-bas depuis un moment
et le gouvernement français a réussi à mieux fermer les frontières,
et donc la « jungle » grandit,
tout comme le désespoir des gens qui y vivent.
BG : Pensez-vous retourner et continuer les reportages ?
TC : Oui.
BG : Anders, je suis un ancien journaliste,
et je trouve extraordinaire
qu'avec les compressions budgétaires, et la crise éditoriale,
Dagbladet vous ait accordé autant de ressources pour cette histoire,
cela montre bien de la prise de responsabilités des journaux,
mais, comment as-tu réussi à vendre cette histoire ?
Anders F : Ce n'était pas facile au début,
car on ne savait pas exactement ce qu'on serait en mesure de retrouver.
Mais dès que c'est devenu clair
qu'on pourrait sûrement identifier au moins l'un d'eux,
on a compris qu'on pouvait faire ce qu'on jugeait nécessaire,
aller où il fallait aller, faire ce qu'il fallait faire
afin de de finir cette mission avec succès.
BG : Voilà un éditeur qui prend ses responsabilités.
L'histoire a été traduite et publiée
dans des nombreux journaux européens, et ceci continuera sans doute.
On espère avoir des mises à jour de votre part. Merci Anders, merci Tom.
(Applaudissements)